in other auto news a Bloomberg exclusive
Sergio marchionni tells Bloomberg News
Ferrari could go public by July he also
said the IPO process should be quick
Matt Miller just sat down with the Fiat
Chrysler automobiles CEO and he joins us
in studio that's big news yeah not just
quick I mean he told our bloomberg news
print reporter mark clothier that he
could sell all of Ferrari shares before
he has time to finish his bagel so
obviously demand is very high the
appetite is strong for Ferraris I
actually asked him how how could i get
some i mean how many Fiat Chrysler
shares would I have to buy in order to
get one Ferrari share he said they
haven't worked out the mechanics
completely but they could have a loyalty
program let's nobody told me what we
have found as if in terms of governance
having some type of loyalty scheme
actually encourages people to be
long-term investments right because in
are the one that we've got in place in
FCA allows you to earn your right to
have the extra votes if you hang onto it
for three years so it's a long-term
commitment strategy in terms of the
shareholder base it may work its way
into Ferrari we don't know yet so very
interesting possibly a european-style
program if you own chairs for a longer
amount of time you get the right to have
a more more more of a say in what
happens in the company he also said
speaking of Europe that that's really a
growth area for them it's been tougher
as competitors obviously it's been
tougher Fiat as well but that's where he
sees a real rebound listen to his
thoughts on the continent European
market los three million cars from its
peak in the last decade I I think that
there is ample opportunity for some of
the three million number addicted to be
clawed back and even though we've got
problems any in Eastern Europe and
obviously the strife initial continues
to
be a significant overhang on the market
but i think the European bloc is bound
to do better so great story by Bloomberg
News Tommaso a bard on the website today
that shows that even though analysts
collectively think it's a cell or the
majority of analysts think it's a sell
the shares are up fifty percent since
they listed and marchionni has brought
Fiat back in the brink of bankruptcy and
then bought Chrysler for a song he's
just done incredibly well with this
company all right Matt Miller on autos
and Fiat Chrysler and of course stay
with Bloomberg TV I'm sure we'll hear
more from you throughout the day yes we
will war from that exclusive interview
for my exclusive sit-down mr. geo
marchionni Matt thanks so much